اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض والتي نقدم من
خلالها ابرز اخبار ملفات السعوديه والخليج
وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
وزير الدفاع البريطاني يقول بان الطريق
امام مشاركه دبابات تشالنجر 2 في اوكرانيا
لازال طويلا
وزير الخارجيه الايراني يؤكد ترحيب بلاده
باي مبادره لانهاء الازمه القائمه في
اليمن
في السعوديه شاب متوفى دماغي ينقذ حياه
خمسه مرضى اخرين بعد تبرعه باعضائه
وفي الرابعه نتناول ايضا
اكتتاب حمله جود الاسكان في السعوديه يجمع
نصف مليار ريال منذ انطلاقه قبل نحو اسبوع
شركه البحر الاحمر الدوليه تعلن عن اطلاق
منتجع روز هود ضمن مشروع امال غربي
السعوديه
حياكم الله مع استمرار الغربي واوروبا
بتقديم المساعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا اكد
وزير الدفاع البريطاني بن ولس ان دبابات
تشالنجر 2 وصلت الى اوكرانيا لدعم قواتها
في مواجهه الهجمات الروسيه مشيرا الى ان
الجنود الاوكرانيين بحاجه الى المزيد من
التدريب واضاف الوزير البريطاني ان الطريق
ما زال طويلا لاستخدامات لاستخدام دبابات
تشالنجر 2 في المعارك
حذر مدير وكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
رافيل جروسي من ان الوضع في محطه زابوريا
النوويه لم يتحسن وقال جروسي خلال زيارته
للمحطه النوويه ان القتال قد احتدم بين
روسيا واوكرانيا بالقرب من المحطه
قال مؤسس مجموعه فاغنر ان عمليات قوته في
باقمه تادت لهزيمه الجيش الاوكراني لكنها
تسببت في اضرار كبيره لقوته كما قال
ايفيجيني ان انتصار فاجنر سيقلب بشكل كبير
العمليات الخاصه راسا على عقب
ومن كيف ينضموا الينا الصحفي محمد البابا
محمد مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض قبل قليل ربما تابعت هذه التصريحات
لمؤسس فاجنر الحديث عن احتدام المعارك في
باقمت القتال على هذه
المعركه ايضا كذلك وبالا استسلام فيها كيف
يمكن تقييم الوضع ميدانيا اولا في باقمه
هذا اليوم
محمد هل تسمعني نعم يعني وضع العمليات
حاليا في مدينه باخموت المعارك يعني مشتده
جدا القصف المتبادل بين الطرفين بين
القوات الروسيه القوات الروسيه التي ارسلت
وحدات عسكريه من سلاح المشاه لدعم يعني
وحدات فاجنر التي تم استندافها استنزافها
بشكل كبير جدا بحسب يعني وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه اكثر من 30 الف من مقاتلي
فاجنرز وبدايه العام حتى الان قضوا في تلك
المعركه الجيش الروسي يعني الانفصاليين
وقوات يحاولون التقدم لحصار مدينه بشكل
كامل بينما القوات الاوكرانيه التي ارسلت
وحدات من الميزانيين والفرق الخاصه التي
اصبحت بالقرب من وتقوم بضرب القوات
الروسيه الان المعركه معركه اشتدت من جديد
بعد اسبوع الى حد ما كان هادئ حصلت يعني
في هذا الاسبوع قدمت يعني وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه الدعم اللوجستى والعسكري للقوات
الروسيه او القوات التي تقاتل في تلك
المنطقه بعد الجيش الاوكراني ايضا كسف
عمليات القصف المدفعي والصاروخي على
مراكز القياده ومخازن الاسلحه التي تقع في
البلدات القريبه من مدينه وايضا الجيش
الاوكراني قصف منطقه مراكز العسكريه
وسكنات عسكريه في مدينه
سقوط عدد من القتلى والجرحى الجيش الروسي
بدوره الان يحاول يعني تشديد القوات
الاوكرانيه بفتح جبهات اخرى مثل جبهه
كريمينيا التي يعني تشترك القوات الروسيه
مع القوات الاوكرانيه التي تحاول التقدم
في تلك المنطقه محور ليمن بالامس وحتى
ساعات الصباح الاولى كان هناك محاولات
تقدم للقوات الروسيه وايضا
بالقرب من مدينه كراماتورس كان هناك قصف
صاروخي ومدفعي من الكويت الروسيه لتجمعات
عسكريه للقوات الاوكرانيه ما يعني ان
الجبهه عادت للاشتداد للاشتعال من جديد
بشكل كبير خاصه
مجموعه باجرار محمد
نايف قبل قليل
حول نباتات تشال
ني
نعم نعم كنت يعني قبل الحديث عن الدبابات
تشالنجر اثنان يعني كنت اود الحديث كذلك
عن دقه ما قاله رئيس مجموعه فاجنر قال بان
عمليات قوته في باخمت ادت لهزيمه الجيش
الاوكراني هذا الحديث الى اي مدى هو دقيق
بما يحدث ميدانيا بموازاته هو ليس
الحقيقه وللواقع القوات الروسيه احتلت
اجزاء من مدينه خاصه منطقه الصناعيه قبل
اسبوعين سقطت يعني كان هناك اشتباكات
عنيفه واصبحت تحت سيطره المدفعيه والنيران
الروسيه بين تحت السيطره الميدانيه
والسيطره الناريه حيث يعني لا يمكن ان
تتواجد في تلك المنطقه بسبب كثافه النيران
ايضا المنطقه الشرقيه انسحبت منها القوات
الاوكرانيه وقام الجيش الاوكراني بتدمير
الجسور على نهر
مما يعني اوقف تمدد القوات الروسيه الى
وسط مدينه لكن خساره الجيش الاوكراني
بمعنى الكلمه هي عندما تصبح مدينه بالكامل
تحت سيطره القوات الروسيه وهذا لم يحصل
حتى هذه اللحظه لا بل ان في بعض المناطق
في بعض الاحياء من الجهه الجنوبيه والجهه
الجنوبيه الغربيه القوات الاوكرانيه لها
اليد العليا باستهداف جميع القوات الروسيه
قوات وانتصار الجيش الاوكراني في تلك
المنطقه هي صموده خلال الفتره الم منذ
اكثر من اربعه اشهر هناك عمليات كبيره
وتعتبر مدينه بخموت هي حرب طاحنه وهي لكسر
القوتين او كسره الجانب الاوكرانيه وخساره
الجانب الروسي محمد اشكرك جزيلا شكر على
كل هذه المعلومات التي مديتنا بها من كيف
الصحه في محمد شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
ادعى وزير الخارجيه الروسيه مؤتمر
الصحفيين عقده مع نظيره الايراني حسين عبد
الهيان في موسكو دعا كل الاطراف للالتزام
بالاتفاق النووي كما رحب بعوده العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين الرياض والطيران
الى استئناف القرار الاممي الخاص بالاتفاق
النووي الايراني والعالم ينتظر عوده
الولايات المتحده الالتزاماتها بخصوص
الاتفاق النووي الايراني
نرحب بانتعاش الاوضاع في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط خاصه على ضوء تجديد العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين السعوديه وايران
من جانبه رحب وزير خارجيه الايرانيه حسين
عبد اللهيان خلال المؤتمر الصحفي في موسكو
رحب باي مبادره لانهاء الحرب في اليمن كما
اكد على اجراء محادثات هاتفيه مع وزير
الخارجيه السعودي لاجراء لقاء مشترك في
اقرب وقت
نرحب بالمحادثات الجاريه بشان اليمن ونرحب
باي مبادره لانهاء الحرب هناك واجريت
محادثات هاتفيه مع وزير الخارجيه السعودي
اكدنا فيها على العلاقات الثنائيه ونقشنا
اجراء لقاءات على المستوى الوزاري وافتتاح
السفارات ولتطوير تلك العلاقات يجب اتخاذ
الخطوات ونحن مستعدون لذلك
من موسكو تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه كاتيا
مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
من الرياض دعيني ابدا اولا من الملفات
التي نوقشت بين
طرفي هذا الاجتماع على المستوى وزراء
الخارجيه
الروسي وكذلك الايراني
وصفهما وصفه الوزيران بانه كان اجتماع
مثمر جدا تم بحث فيه اهم الملفات
الدوليه والاقليميه اولا خطه العمل
الشامله
الملف النووي الايراني وعوده طبعا جميع
بالاهم طبعا على راسهم لولايه المتحده
الامريكيه الى هذا الاتفاق اكد وزير
الخارجيه الروسيه انه لا بديل للاتفاق
النووي الايراني وانه طبعا في حال تم
الاتخاذ القرار للعوده الى هذا الاتفاق
يجب ان يكون طبعا
بمتواجد روسيا والصين بالاضافه لذلك تم
بحث الملف السوري
وتحدث وزير الخارجيه الايراني عن عقد
اجتماع رباعي في موسكو في الاسبوع المقبل
بين وزير نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي
والتركي والسوري والايراني وكما قال ايضا
هو هذا الاجتماع يهدف الى تقريب او وجهات
النصر بين تركيا وبين سوريا كما تعلم نايف
كان هناك ايضا زياره الى للرئيس السوري
الى موسكو في وقت سابق وذلك من ايضا تم
بحث امكانيه تطبيع العلاقات مع بين سوريا
وبين تركيا بالاضافه الى ذلك تم بحث
العلاقات الاقتصاديه بين البلدين واشاد
الوزيران
بالتبادل الايجاري التجاري او حجم التبادل
التجاري بين البلدين الذي كما تحدث ايضا
الوزير الايراني بانه زاد بنسبه ثلاثه مئه
ونصف خلال عام ونصف بين البلدين طبعا
مؤتمر الصحفي بين الوزيرين حمل عده رسائل
الى الشرق الاوسط
ما الذي جاء من رسائل في هذا السياق كاتيا
يمكن الوقوف عندها عناوين رئيسيه لهذا
المؤتمر الصحفي
صحيح نايف اولا كان وزير الخارجيه
الايراني اكد على ان ايران ترحب باي
مبادره تخص عمليه حل الازمه في اليمن
بالاضافه لذلك كان هو تطرق الى موضوع
استعاده العلاقات بين ايران وبين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه التي تم استئنافها مؤخرا
والذي قال طبعا انه سيلتقي بنظيره السعودي
في المستقبل القريب واكد على اهميه طبعا
السلام بين ايران ودول المجاوره لها هو
قال ان هناك وجهات نظر مختلفه مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ولكنها لن تقوم او لن
تعيق تطوير العلاقات بين البلدين شكرا
جزيلا لك من موسكو مراسله العربيه كاتيا
طعمها على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
مباشره الى هذه الصور لاستقبال الملك
تشيلسي في برلين في اول زياره خارجيه له
وطبعا الرئيس الالماني فرانك فالتر هو من
يستقبل الملك
تشيلسي في العاصمه
الالمانيه برلين في اول زياره خارجيه
للملك تشارلز اذا وصل الملك البريطاني
الملك تشارلز الى وجهته الخارجيه الاولى
الى العاصمه الالمانيه برلين وكما تابعنا
قبل قليل بدات هذه الزياره باستقبال الملك
تشارلز من قبل
فرانك فلتر الرئيس الالماني
اذا اول زياره خارجيه
له طبعا كان قد تاخر ثلاثه ايام عن الموعد
المقرر وعلى بعد 885 كيلو مترا شمال الشرق
الدوله التي كان يرغب ان تكون اولى وجهاته
كملك اذا كان طبعا يود ان تكون هذه الوجهه
هي باريس
اهداف الزياره ايضا كما وصفت تظل بانها
تعزيز للعلاقات البريطانيه مع اوروبا
واظهار قدره المملكه المتحده في
يعني بهذه المعركه التي توصف بانها معركه
الكسب في القاره اذا هذه صور
نتابعها مباشره لوصول الملك تشارلز الى
العاصمه الالمانيه برلين في اول زياره
خارجيه له
وافق مجلس الوزراء السعودي الذي عقد
برئاسه الملك سلمان وافق على تعديل عدد من
مواد تنظيم هيئه حقوق الانسان كما وافق
على اتفاقيه مقر بين الرياض والمجلس
الدولي للتمور المجلس وافق ايضا خلال
الجلسه على مذكره حول منح السعوديه صفه
شريك في منظمه شنغهاي للتعاون
للتعاون هي مجموعه دوليه سياسيه واقتصاديه
وامنيه تاسست عام 2001 وتضم في عضويتها
تسعه دول كما تهدف لدعم الامن ومحاربه
الارهاب بالاضافه الى تعزيز التعاون
الاقتصادي والتجاري من اعطاء منظمه شنغهاي
الهند وباكستان الصين وروسيا
الرابع مستمره وفي بعد قليل ايضا
في السعوديه شاب متوفن دماغيا ينقذ حياه
خمسه مرضى اخرين بعد تبرعه باعضائه
حياكم الله من جديد اعلن المركز السعودي
لزراعه الاعضاء عن انقاذ حياه خمسه مرضى
بعد نجاح الفرق الطبيه في نقل اعضاء الشاب
متوفى دماغيا تبرع باعضائه قبل الوفاه
المركز السعودي اوضح ايضا ان الاعضاء التي
تمكنت الفرق الطبيه من زراعتها هي
الكليتان والكبد والرئه بالاضافه الى
زراعه القلب
ينضموا الينا هنا في الاستوديو الطبيب
والمنسق الاكلينيكي في المركز السعودي
لزراعه الاعضاء الدكتور خالد الروقي دكتور
خالد حياك الله ما يعرف نشرت الرائعه من
الرياض وخلينا نعرف اولا تفاصيل قصه هذا
المتبرع متى يعني تبرع الاعضاء استعرضناها
ربما ايضا قبل قليل لكن نريد تفاصيل اكثر
عن هذه الحاله هذه الحاله طبعا هي قصه
بطوليه الامانه يعني هي مثل مثل كثير من
حالات الوفاه الدماغيه تبدا بماسه لكنها
تنتهي بعطاء واعطاء اصلا حياه
لمرضى اخرين في الحاله هذه خمسه مرضى من
اعضاء من اللي عندهم فشل عضوي استفادوا من
اعضاء هذه المتوفين طبعا هي بدات الحاله
بدخول للمتوفي للمستشفى حاول اطباء انه
يعالجونه ينقضون حياته لكن قدره الله
بعد كذا وصلنا البلاغ عن المركز
عمره تقريبا 33 سنه
احنا قابلنا الاهل جلسنا مع اهل المتوفي
طبعا هو شاب الاب والام جلست معهم كذلك
اخوه واللي هو كان موجود في المملكه
والحمد لله احسن منهم على موافقه جد النبي
لو جدا مشكورين فيها الهدف منها انه تبرع
بالاعضاء
للمرضى رحمه الله عليه طيب
خليني اسال عن المركز اليوم عن اعداد
المسجلين حاليا في السعوديه بالتبرع
بالاعضاء كما وصل العدد الى الان الحمد
لله الى الان وصل العدد الى 500 وسبعه الف
متبرع او راغب بالتبرع اللي هم بعد الوفاه
وتاثر عليها اللي هو بطاقه المتبرع
يعني رقم رقم جدا جميل بس احنا نطمح باذن
الله ان يكون العدد اكبر بكثير 500000 500
كيف النمو في اعداد المسجلين يعني انتم
كيف رصدتوه خلال الفتره الماضيه هل هل
النمو متزاي ومتسارع ولا في فترات مثلا
متقطعه النمو الحمد لله في تزايد
وخصوصا ودي اشيل الذكر انه بدايتها كانت
في 2021 في شهر رمضان كانت في مبادره
كريمه من اسمها سيدي خادم الحرمين
الشريفين ولي عهده حفظهم الله انه كان
عنده مبادره بتسجيلك متبرعين ورغبين
وكانوا اول المقدمين في الرغبه والتبرع
وطلع على اثر البطاقه ومن بعدها الناس
بدات تسجل كمتبرعين وحمزه الارقام في
تزايد باذن الله تكون بتكون اعلى بكثير في
السنوات القادمه يعني من 2021 الى 2023
حنتكلم على 5000 صح تقريبا شخص
الاحتياج الحالي اليوم لزراعه الاعضاء في
السعوديه او خليني اتكلم للحالات اللي
خلينا نقول تعاني من فشل عضوي في تقديرات
معينه لها عندكم اي موجوده انا ودي صراحه
اشرح الصوره طبعا هو في ازدياد كبير في
المرضى اللي عنده فشل عضوي نهائي وبالاخص
الفشل الكلوي او يعني كل واحد منا ممكن
يعرف شخص او شخصين عندهم مشاكل في الكلى
ويمكن يمرون بالغسيل في احد مراكز الغسيل
في نفس الوقت عندنا في زياده في عدد
المتبرعين لكن ما يغطي الحاجه
لمرضى الفشل العضوي يعني احنا عندنا حاجه
اكثر من عدد المتابعين بالضبط بالضبط مع
انه في ازداد في الارقام كلها فعلى سبيل
المثال انا بعطيك هم يقيسونها على عدد
المتبرعين في كل مليون نسمه عندنا في
السعوديه كان في 2021 وصل العدد او النسبه
الى
2.9 بالمئه فئه 2.9 لكل مليون نسمه منهم
يطلع متبرع الزاد العدد في 2020 الى 3.5
طبعا لو قررناها بدون مفترض يكون يعني لو
قرنا بدول العالم يوصلون الى عشره الى عنا
هدفنا 15% من مليون شخص 15
متبرع لكل مليون شخص فاحنا نضربها في عدد
النسمه نسمه الموجوده في البلد وتعرف كم
كم النسبه كم المطلوب احنا طبعا هدفنا
نوصل الى عشره من ثلاثه فاصله عشره اشخاص
من كل لكل لكل مليون متبرع لكل مليون
متبرع وفي طبعا الاحصائيه ثاني برضو تشرح
الصوره اللي هم عدد
عمليات الزراعه وطبعا هذا يشمل العمليات
في الاحياء واللي المتوفين احنا وصلنا الى
خمسين عمليه زراعه لكل
لكل مليون نسمه هدفنا نوصل فيها ان شاء
الله الى 65 عمليه
وطبعا هذا شغله مهمه جدا طبعا يشمل
الاحياء والمتوفين وجديد بالذكر انه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ولا الحمد تعتبر
المركز الثاني عالميا من ناحيه المتبرين
الاحياء
اعلى الدول في العالم تبرع في الاحياء من
المركز الثاني تعتبر المملكه هذا شيء جدا
جبار ان شاء الله تكون في المركز الاول
قريبا جزيل الشكر في الاستديو الطبيب
والمنسق الاكلينيكي في المركز السعودي
لزراعه الاعضاء الدكتور خالد الروقي شكرا
يا دكتور
خصصت رئاسه العمل لشؤون المسجد الحرام 25
موظفا يعملون على قياس رضا المعتمرين
وكافه الخدمات المقدمه لهم من خلال خمسه
وسبعين لوحه تمكن الزائرين من ابداء رايهم
لوحات تمكن الزائرين من ابداء رايهم حول
الخدمات المقدمه لهم في المسجد الحرام
وذلك
للتحسين منها
[موسيقى]
توافد كبير وطاقه قصوى للمسجد الحرام في
استقبال مئات الالاف من المعتمرين والزوار
يوميا خلال شهر رمضان هذه الاعداد الكبيره
تتطلب تطويرا مستمرا للخدمات عبر قياسي
رضاهم عن الخدمات المقدمه تعمل اداره تج
الرحمن وفق معايير متبعه من مركز اداء
الوطني لقياس الجهات الحكوميه كذلك تعمل
الاداره على اربع ورديات مختلفه تقوم
بقياس نسبه الرضا وفق معايير معتمده من
مركز ادال وطني لقياس الجهات الحكوميه
يقوم يقوم الفريق الميداني في النزول على
ارض الواقع واخذ الانطباعات مباشره ورفع
تقارير لحظيه مسوح احصائيه ميدانيه تجريها
وكاله قياس الاداء والجوده بالرئاسه
العامه لشؤون المسجد الحرام بشكل يومي حيث
تستهدف استطلاع اراء خمسه الاف معتمر
ومصلل يقوم المختصين لدى المركز بعمليه
المقابله الشخصيه مع المعتمرين
وسؤالهم عن المده المستغرقه في كل قسم من
هذه الاقسام الخاصه بالعمره سواء في
الطواف او في السعي او مده الانتقال بين
الطواف والسعيد وبعد ذلك يقوم مركز
الاحصاء والمعلومات باخذ متوسط مده
المتوسط مده العمره جاهزيته المصليات
واعمال النظافه واداره الحشود ابرز
الخدمات التي يجري بحث رضا المعتمرين عنها
لتفادي اي اخطاء فيما تبقى من شهر رمضان
واستعدادا للموسم الاكبر موسم حج هذا
العام من الحرم المكي سلطان السلمي
العربيه
خصصت رئاسه الحرمين ما يزيدوا عن 160 بابا
للمسجد الحرام خلال شهر رمضان وذلك لدخول
وخروج معتمرين والمصلين وانسيابيه حركتهم
فيما تقوم اكثر من سبع وعشرين جهه حكوميه
وخاصه بدعم واسع داخل الحرم المكي
من الحرم المكي ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
هاني باصفيان هاني مساء الخير مرحبا بكم
معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
هاني نتحدث عن 160 بابا للمسجد الحرام يتم
من خلاله دخول وخروج
المعتمرين الزائرين وايضا كذلك
المصلين في المسجد الحرام كيف تبدو الصوره
ما الذي رصدته ايضا في هذه العمليه الدخول
والخروج والتنظيم هناك
[موسيقى]
صحيح نعم نايف واهلا بك واهلا بمشاهدين
قناه العربيه في حقيقه الامر ان ابواب
المسجد الحرام هي اكثر من ذلك 210 ابواب
ولكن التي خصصتها رئاسه شؤون نعم التي
خصصت رئاسه شؤون الحرمين للمعتبين خلال
هذه الفتره حتى الان 160 كما تفضلت وهي من
ضمن الابواب التي
خصصتها سواء للدخول المعتمرين او المصلين
او كذلك للخروج وترتفع
بامكان زياده هذا العدد مع اعداد اذا زادت
من المعتمرين او كذلك المصلين خلال الفتره
القادمه الصوره التي تشاهدها خلفيه واحده
من المداخل التي تم تخصيصها من قبل من قبل
رئاسه شؤون الحرمين وكذلك من ضمن الخطه
التشغيليه نشاهد رغم الكثافه العدديه الا
ان الحركه انسيابيه وكذلك حركه المعتمرين
الذين يتوجهون الى صحن وخاصه نحن نتواجد
في الطابق السفلي فان العمليه تتم بكل يسر
وسهوله من ضمن ايضا الاطار التنظيمي التي
قامت بها رئاسه شؤون الحرمين هي خصصت ايضا
مطوفين من اجل الاستعانه بهم في حاله
احتاج المعتمر الى هذا المطوف للحديث عن
المطوفين تحديدا سوف ينضم معي الاستاذ
احمد الدهاس وهو مدير اداره المطوفين
والتطويف في رئاسه شؤون الحرمين اولا دعنا
نعرف من هم المطوفين ما العمل الذي يقومون
به كم عددهم ما الذي يستعين بهم او من هم
الذين يستعين بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
حياكم الله واهلا وسهلا بكم في رحاب
المسجد الحرام وفي هذا الشهر الفضيل
الرئاسه العامه لشؤون المسجد الحرام
المسجد النبوي وبتوجيهات الرئيس العام
لشؤون الحرمين معالي الشيخ عبد الرحمن
السديس تقدم خدمه التطويف
للمستفيدين وطالبين الخدمه من داخل المسجد
الحرام وذلك من خلال المشايات
موجوده في داخل المسجد الحرام مثل مشايه
الملك عبد العزيز رحمه الله مشايه الملك
فهد رحمه الله مشايه باب العمره ومشايه
باب الفتح وكذلك مشايه باب السلام
يستقبل المطوفين
يستقبل المطوفين المعتمرين وضيوف الرحمن
وارشادهم
بطريقه صحيحه اي مؤتمر او كذلك حاج في
موسم الحج نعم الخدمه متاحه على مدار
السنه لمن يرغم من الاستفاده بالخدمه
لدينا في شهر رمضان المبارك تقريبا ما
يقارب سبعين مطوف يقومون بالخدمه لخدمه
التطويف كذلك يزداد العدد في موسم الحج
تقريبا يصل عددهم الى 200 مطوف هذا المطوف
يعني هنا عدد من المطوفين الذين يعني
يقفون بجنبي الان ونشاهدهم عبر شاشه
العربيه ما المهام الذي يؤديها وهل هم
دربوا ومؤهلين بان يكونوا بجانب المعتمرين
او الحجاج في موسم الحج طبعا لدينا نحن
برنامج تدريبي على مدار السنه في فن
التعامل مع ضيوف الرحمن كذلك في تعظيم
البلد الحرام كذلك في طريقه
والتعامل مع ضيوف الرحمن
الدورات مستمره خلال يعني على مدار السنه
اي نعم يعطون ادعيه مثلا يرشدونهم
بالادعيه وش المهام
اللي يقول نعم المطوفين من مهام عملهم هو
التعريف الحجاج وضيوف الرحمن والمعتمرين
في هذا الشهر الكريم
اركان العمره وواجبات العمره وسنن العمره
كذلك محظورات الاحرام يعني يفيد الينا في
المشايات يعني بعض المعتمرين يوجد عليه
بعض المخالفات في محظورات الاحرام
فالاخوان المطوفين جزاهم الله خير يقومون
بتوعيتهم بالطريقه الصحيحه ويفقل هذه هل
هديه النبوي الصحيح يعني لديكم مختلف عن
المشايات المتعارف عند الناس توضحنا مصطلح
المشايات المشايه المصطلح المشايه هو
مصطلح دارج لدينا في المسجد الحرام بين
الموظفين والعاملين داخل المسجد الحرام ما
هو الطريق المؤدي من بدايه الباب الرئيسي
مثلا باب الملك عبد العزيز رحمه الله الى
مدخل المطاف هذا يعتبر لدينا مشايخ نعم من
الباب الملك عبد العزيز الرئيسي من هذا
المدخل تقريبا طبعا الباب في الخلف
والذي يتجه مباشره الى الكعبه نعم هذه
تسمى مشايه ولها الوان معينه يعني زي مش
الملك عبد العزيز باللون الاخضر مشايه
الملك فهد باللون الذهبي وقس على ذلك يعني
شكرا لك استاذ احمد الدهاس وهو الذي عرف
لنا وايضا اعطانا نبذه عن المطوفين الذين
يقومون
معتمرين الذين يستعينون بهؤلاء المطوفين
وهي من ضمن خدمات رئاسه شؤون الحرمين طبعا
هؤلاء المطوفين هم يقومون مع المعتمرين
بجانبهم ويعطونهم بعض الادعيه وكذلك
الادعيه الصحيحه وكذلك يرشدونهم على النسك
او الركن الاساسي والطريقه الصحيحه في
حاله عن طريقه طريقه اعتمارهم وكذلك لبس
للاحرام وايضا كيف يبداون ومتى ينتهون
طبعا هنا سوف نقوم بالدخول الى صحن المطاف
ورغم الاعداد والكثافه العدديه الا ان
الحركه كما تشاهد الان وايضا ما زلنا
نواصل الخطوات نحو صحن المطاف الا عمليه
هي سليسه وكذلك انسيابيه ضمن الخطه
التشغيليه وضمن الاستراتيجيه التى خصصتها
رئاسه شؤون الحرمين عزيزي نايف شكرا جزيلا
لك هنيئا اصفيان ولضيفك الكريم من الحرم
المكي مراسل العربيه هاني نصفيا شكرا يا
هاني
المصلين والمعتمرين في الحرم المكي خلال
شهر رمضان تواصل الجهات الامنيه والخدميه
تنفيذ خطتها الميدانيه داخل الحرم وفي
الساحات الخارجيه حيث تمت تهيئه 120 مسلا
في التوسعه الجديده وذلك لاستيعاب كما
ذكرنا الاعداد المتزايده من المعتمرين
والمصلين وللدخول الحرم المكي مشاهدينا تم
تخصيصه عده ابواب تضمن انسيابيه الحركه
حيث تم تخصيص الباب رقم 100 ضمن الابواب
الرئيسيه اضافه الى سته ابواب في الجهه
الشماليه وخمسه ابواب في الجهه الغربيه
وثلاثه في الجهه الشرقيه للمسجد وذلك
لخدمه كافه المحاور المؤديه لتوسيعه
السعوديه الثالثه الابواب المخصصه هذه
مشاهدينا تسهل وصول المصلين للمصليات في
مختلف ادوار المسجد الحرام كما تسهل ايضا
وصول المصلين الى سطح الذي يستخدم لاول
مره وتمثل نسبه مئه في المئه من اجمالي
الطاقه الاستيعابيه لمبنى التي تستوعب 300
الف مصلا ولضمان ح سلسله للمعتمرين
والزوار تم تشغيل سلالم الكهربائيه التي
يتجاوز عددها 360 سلما كهربائيا
والاستفاده من 26 مصعدا كهربائيا وتجهيز
4000 دوره مياه منها اثنتان وسبعون دوره
مخصصه للاشخاص ذوي الاعاقه كما تم تعزيز
جوده منظومه التكييف والاضاءه وسلامه
الصوت بالاضافه الى تزويد المصليات باثنين
وعشرين الف سجاده
بعد مرور الاسبوع الاول من شهر رمضان تخطت
حمله جود الاسكان الخيريه التابعه لمنصه
جوده الاسكان حاجزه نصف ملياريال حيث
تجاوزت الحمله نصف القيمه المستهدفه لها
والبالغه مليار ريال وذلك بهدف توفير
المساكن لثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه من الاسر
الاشد حاجه هذا وتعد منصه جود الاسكان
احدى مبادره مؤسسه الاسكان التنموي
والهادفه لاشراك افراد المجتمع في برامج
التنميه المجتمعيه وتقديم المساعده للاسر
المحتاجه
اعلنت وزاره الطاقه السعوديه عن اطلاق 17
مشروعا جديدا للطاقه المتجدده منذ تدشين
مبادره السعوديه الخضراء قبل نحوي عامين
محققه المركز الاول عالميا في نمو انتاج
الطاقه المتجدده كما تصدرت السعوديه قائمه
الدول العربيه في مؤشر خبط الانبعاثات
قطاع طاقه السعودي حقق كذلك تقدما عالميا
بعشر مراكز في مؤشر المستقبل الاخضر
اعلنت شركه البحر الاحمر الدوليه عن توقيع
عقد شراكه مع فنادق ومنتجعه روزود
العالميه لاطلاق منتجع روز وود اماله الذي
يركز على الاستدامه والاستجمام على امتداد
الخط الساحلي منتجع روز وود امال الواقع
في منطقه البحر الاحمر يشمل 110 اجنحه
ومحاط برابع اكبر مساحه مرجانيه في العالم
[موسيقى]
دفعت الامطار المتفرقه التي شهدتها منطقه
حائل خلال الايام الماضيه دفعت الكثير من
العوائل للاستمتاع بالاجواء الربيعيه
والرمضانيه في المنتزهات البريه والتي تضم
العديد من المنتجات الصحراويه والمحميات
الطبيعيه وعلى راسها محميه الملك سلمان
الملكيه التي تتميز بطبيعتها وتنوعها
الجغرافي والتراثي والاثار نادره التي
يعود بعضها لثمانيه الاف سنه قبل الميلاد
من حائل ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد
الرحمن العصيمي عبد الرحمن مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
كلمني عن هذه الاجواء الربيعيه اجواء ما
بعد المطر عبد الرحمن مثل ما ذكرت في
الخبر العادات ايضا حتى والتقاليد
الرمضانيه لها الحايل
فعلا نايف اجواء رائعه جدا خاصه الامطار
لا تزال تهطل بين وقت واخر قبل يومين كان
في امطار على حايل متوقع ايضا خلال
الاسبوع القادم ربما يكون فيه امطار على
منطقه حاسد على الصوره تتحدث وتنقل لكم
الاجواء الرائعه جدا كنا قبل قليل نايف في
سد توارن هذا السد الشهير في حائل التقدم
له بعض الصور لعل الزملاء ظهورها على
الشاشه الان هذا السد الذي تفقده نائب
امير منطقه حائل قبل تقريبا شهر ونصف
تقريبا للوقوف على يعني
استعدادات السدود المائيه في حائل والتي
تشكل اهميه كبيره للمزارعين وايضا
للبيئه ايضا حائل نايف تشتهر بجبالها
الرائعه جبال اجى وسلمى وايضا جبل القاعد
وجبال اخرى كما نشاهد الان على الصوره هذه
المنتزهات استغلها اهالي حايل نايف لي
الافطار في نهار في شهر رمضان
للاستمتاع بالاجواء الربيعيه طبعا الان
تقريبا ساعتين على اذان المغرب فالناس
كلها تجي يا نايف قبل الفطور تقريبا نصف
ساعه 40 دقيقه لتجهيزات الافطار
والاستمتاع بالاجواء الربيعيه ايضا نايف
ما يميز حايل حقيقه هي تمسكهم بالعادات
الاصيله التقليديه في الايام القليله
المقبله ستشاهدون تقرير ضمن سلسله رمضان
معهم عن ابرز العادات والتقاليد الرمضانيه
مثلا
جمعه الاهل والاصدقاء على الافطار يوميا
هذه ضروريه جدا ايضا صلاه التراويح والحرص
عليها وقراءه القران بعد صلاه التراويح من
قبل اهالي الحاره هذه ايضا عاده قديمه ولا
تزال مستمره حتى الان ايضا الاكلات
الشعبيه نايف الهريس والجريش والمرقوق
والمطازيز وغيرها من الاكلات الشهيره
الرمضانيه موجوده
ايضا هذه الاجواء الربيعيه نايف شجعت
الكثير حتى من اهالي حايل للتطوع
وتنظيف هذه المنتزهات البريه للاسف بعض
الناس لا يزالون يعني من ناحيه النظافه
والاهتمام هناك بعض الاهمال لكن لا يزالون
هناك مجموعات تطوعيه تقوم
بالحرص والحفاظ على هذه المنتزهات نشاهد
الان هذه بعض الاشجار والازهار البريه
الخزامه هذا اللون البنفسجي رائع نايف
يعني اجواء رائعه جدا انا صراحه اتمناك
معاي يا نايف ان شاء الله تزور حايل في
القريب العاجل
عبد الرحمن
بتكون احلى واجمل لكن نحتاج انسان من راجح
يا عبد الرحمن ولا خلاص اخذت على المكان
لا سالم التقيت فيه البارح وما قصر معانا
وقام بالواجب وزياده طبعا كل اهل حائل
نايف صراحه الكرم والطيبه والفزعه يعني
هذه هذه
ومنازل وقبر حاتم الطائي لا يبعد عننا الا
تقريبا اربع دقائق بالسياره لكن للاسف
الشبكه هناك ضعيفه وهذه بعض الشكاوى من
المواطنين انه بعض متساهات البريه الرائعه
الشبكه الهاتف فيها ضعيفه بعض الشيء لكن
هناك وعود من شركات الاتصالات لتقويه هذه
الشبكه فلذلك اضطرينا نجي في هذا المنتزه
لكن داخل في سده وارن والشعيب اللي في
الداخل هناك مناظر طبيعيه رائعه جدا ربما
تشاهدوها معنا في التقارير في الايام
العافيه عبد الرحمن استمتع بالاجواء
والافطار في في هالمكان الرائع من حائل
انضم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن
العصمي شكرا يا عبد الرحمن
تعود قصص اللاجئين السوريين الى الشاشه
هذه المره في لبنان التي يجسدها مسلسل
النار بالنار المسلسل الجدلي المكون من 30
حلقه يعرض موضوع النزوح والمشاكل التي
ترافقه يجمع عبد فهد وكارث بشار وجورج
خباز بالاضافه الى اهم الفنانين السوريين
واللبنانيين المزيد في فقره كواليس مع سهى
واعداد ايهما القاسم
[موسيقى]
حاول يكون عزيز عامل شيدو السوريه
بدنا نقطع الكهرباء عن الحاره كلها
مرحبا
عماله مثيره للفضول هذا العام في رمضان
مسلسل للنار بالنار والسبب جراه موضوعه
واللي تتناول بعض المشاكل اللي تواجه
اللاجئين السوريين في لبنان بجراه كبيره
من بطوله النجمين عابد فهد وكاريس بشار
حاولنا نوصل فكره جدا موضوعيه ونكون جدا
وسطيين وما نكون ميالين لطرف اكثر من طرف
كونه خلفيه هذا المسلسل بيحكي عن الصراع
السوري اللبناني يلي سببه بالاساس سياسي
والناس تبنوه بس على الصعيد الانساني
بتكتشف انه حقيقه ما في خلاف على الصعيد
الانساني ولكن في رواسب عديده
والام وجروح وطبعا نزلت على المنطقه
الاساسيه اللي هي عايشه فيها بسوريا
اكيد كل السوريين بيعرفوها اسمها الشيخ
محي الدين ومن هناك انطلقت بانه مريم كيف
بتمشي وليش هيك بتمشي المسلسل المؤلف من
30 حلقه من تاليف رامي كوسا واخراج محمد
عبد العزيز يشارك فيه بالبطوله ايضا
الفنانين جورج خباز الطوني عيسى زينه مكي
طارق تميم وكثير غيرهم ويحظى حاليا بنسبه
مشاهده عاليه وسط الكثير من الجدل على
مواقع التواصل ما بين فئات تعزز الاحداث
كواقع وافئات تصف بالمبالغه الرؤيه الفنيه
والمعالجه انا برايي انه كيف ممكن نحن
نتطرق لهذه الاشكاليه بدون ما يكون له شكل
اخباري او نيوز يعني كيف تتم معالجته
دراميا هون اهميه هذا المشروع مسلسل نار
بالنار بعتقد اول مسلسل مشترك لبناني سوري
مبرر عم يحكي عن هالصراع ما بين الشعبين
والصداقات كمان مش بس الصراعات فمسلسل
حقيقي جدا شخصيه انطوائيه عنده اسباب
وعنده تاريخه بين فقد بالحرب
وخاطفينه بوقتها السوريين فعنده اذا بدك
حقد كبير على السوريين وهذا الشيء بيترجمه
بتعاطيه مع الناجحين السوريين يلي بيكونوا
اللي بيجوا على على الحاره اللي هو ساكن
فيها انا عم بلعب شخصيه
مواطن عادي اسمه جميل كان صحافه وهو يساري
شيوعي يعني صار عنده انكسار من الثوره
بالبلد وصار عنده انكسار من انتماءه
السياسي من خطو السياسي اللي ماشي عليه
الحياه ما بصير تلعب معه
وهي اللحظه
اتاكدت انه ابليس اللي جواتي طلعوا
[موسيقى]
للشيخ الهندي
عندك ماضي مع السوري
ين
[موسيقى]
الماء وعصب وجوهر الحياه وهو احد اركان
الكون تفاصيل اسرار هذه الماده في تقويم
معقد الزعل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اعصب وجوهره الحياه وعنصر الاساسي الماء
سواء كان نازلا من السماء يوم مستقرا على
الارض فهو احد اركان الكون فالسماوات خلقت
من بخاره والارض من زبده والعرب سكان
صحراء قاحله وجافه متراميه الاطراف واهل
تنقل وترحل طلبا لموارده ولاهميته ذكره
المولى في 57 موضعا وفي اربعين سوره وحثنا
المصطفى صلى الله عليه وسلم بعدم الاسراف
فيه وقال لا تسرف في الماء ولو كنت على
نهر جاري
الم ترى ان الماء يخبث طعمه وان كان لون
الماء ابيضا صافيا
[تصفيق]
وللماء مجازات عند العرب يدل على العزه لا
تسقني ماء الحياه بذله بل فاسقني بالعز
كاس الحنظلي وعلى قله الحياه اذا قل ماء
الوجه طل حياؤه ولا خير في وجه اذا قلماؤه
ويدل ايضا على الجمال فما زادني الواشون
الا صبابه ولا زادني الناهون الا تماديا
الم تعلمي يا عذبه الماء انني اظل اذا لم
اسقى ماكي صاديه
[موسيقى]
ختام الرابعه بابرز عناوينها
وزير الدفاع البريطاني يقول بان الطريق
امام مشاركه دبابات تشالنجر 2 في اوكرانيا
لا زال طويلا
وزير الخارجيه الايراني يؤكد الترحيب
بلاده باي مبادره لانهاء الازمه القائمه
في اليمن
وفي السعوديه شاب متوفى دماغيا ينقذ حياه
خمسه مره اخرين بعد تبرعه باعضائه
اكتتاب حمله جود الاسكان في السعوديه يجمع
نصف مليار ريال منذ انطلاقه قبل نحو اسبوع
شكرا لكم على اكرم المتابعه نهايه الرابعه
الى اللقاء